bio de vendre ses squeeze aujourd'hui
c'est une question pour vous est ce que
vous avez déjà rêvé d'être un chat avoir
des massages gratuits manger et dormir
réa voire des massages gratuits
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur parcours
qui est une vraie simulation de chat ces
partis star game le j'utilise adrian
engine iv qui est un moteur graphique
c'est beau gosse
attendez quoi le shaq est d'être comme
ça a déjà et je lui fais pas confiance
le matin tu te lèves vitres hier comme
ça alors comment ça se passe et ce qui
peut que marcher déjà ce char ok clic
droit pour courir on peut sauter je
suppose oui oh [ __ ] puis les bien
maladroit à quoi bon aller là où par
exemple qui sait que ça what parcours
cat
qu'est ce qui se passe et qu'on sur les
murs ouais d'accord ok attend avec ce
chien a carrément régime quoi pourtant
on dirait pas comme ça au rex un petit
groupe pense qu'à manger qui tu sais que
ça d'accord c'est des pièces que je dois
ramasser y en a 30 un peu partout ici je
pense je leur en reverser 20 vase c'est
faux que faute en phase là pour y
arriver à temps parce que j'ai peur de
rater besson moi j'suis pas un chat au
quai haut c'est beau et c'est horrible à
temps mais c'est les vases ou des
ballons de baudruche qui ont une forme
de base à 1 on a vu le scandale on casse
tout son faux bond à ces joutes non
[ __ ] de weert et des croquettes pour
moi hein je mettrai dans ma bouche ici
regardez up
non elle s'est cognée la tête trauma
crânien il faut vraiment qu'ils assez
vous regardez au plat à temps mais
tranquillement quoi c'est pas il fait un
saut il se met à marcher trois
kilomètres heure contre les brûlures à
la verticale bleus joueront bush a fait
ça je regarde qu'armand bizarre quoi
derrière mon chèque qui veut se barrer
regardez moi ça je sais que tu vois je
avec un chat je suis jaloux
revenons à ce chat qui est bien plus
intéressant c'est parce qu'elle y croire
et aussi intéressante que que lui mais
t'as pas cette fantastique tête de chat
blasé temps mais se chassent carrément
shell plus gâtés du monde quoi regarder
la maison immense qu'il a pour lui un
nombre de conneries impressionnant qui
peut faire la seconde
hum hum ton cerveau ils se décrochent
avant l'arrivée quoi bon jour plantes
vous avez peur de moi je suis terrifiant
ciel au changement tant attendu et c'est
que ça non mon dieu a web style un bon
équilibre a nommé on se roule c'est que
fils et cher ont aboli qu'il est
finalement on le sait mais non aux
presque voyais arriver parce qu'on est
un peu des chats nous c'est finalement
non non [ __ ] c'est la grande chute à
voile a parfait sa bombe
bonsoir je faisais un chacun avant celle
où attend il raconte le frigo ya peint
tout cas fait attendait regardez ninja
chobo hop là non dans l'autre sens vers
le haut ou vers le bas vers le haut elle
me regarde pas et tonnerre blasé au
revoir
non je le savais mais qu'est ce qui se
passe avec cette que là mais tu pourrais
me laisser quelqu'un avec sa attention
d'accueil comme attiré à travers le mur
est ce que quelqu'un s'en sert comme
téléphone de l'autre côté du mur mais
arrête arrête [ __ ] je vois accéder à
l'achat d'armes en achat il se fait
guide puis carrément longtemps quoi il
peut se coucher ou pas voilà leader je
sais il est spécial au caissier passé
mon chien est décédé
mon chèque elle m'a fait peur le coup
chez que tu es au bord du décès vu la
tête que tu fais mais quand même il a
l'air tellement blasé tout ce qu'il fait
il savoir blasé quoi o comme c'était
beau à regarder mais que voilà toujours
de bonnes surprises comme des rachats
ouais parce que je puisse remonter s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît non atteints
de maltraiter je suis bloqué j'appelle
mon maître à terme et la télé est
immense en fait on un château on accorde
un bon gros bébé chat et on est blasé
détenait est-ce qu'il est blasé quand il
boit du vin il boit pas du vin ses
pectoraux boivent du vin n'y a pas une
chatte dans l'appartement je passe je
vois des verres et des bouteilles de vin
partout je me dis que c'est passé un
truc entre sofia et un autre chat ça se
trouve en fait c'est pas l'appartement
des propriétaires du chat blessé
l'appartement de ce chat ils ont tout
prévu les saligauds arrête mais qui doit
céder le chapeau céder aux mets
j'atteins ski inouïe avril quand je dis
que c'est ma maison regarder ça c'était
mon père au chapeau de paille et à la
veste hipsters voilà mon mon père était
un chien pisteur et j'ai hérité de sa
maison peut le voir de plus près on peut
d'abord marcher sur le tableau voilà en
guise de reconnaissance
merci pour la maison aux papas
ok ce mouvement n'est tellement pas
naturel maintenant regarder up non et
non je suis parfaitement camoufler voilà
mais m me cherchent ils viennent dans ce
coin il me voit pas ses taux aux os oui
et là du coup je peux accéder aux vastes
normalement oh oui allez de base a coulé
m d'allègement flammes un peu trop pour
le jeu sur lequel on joue là ça suffit
mais allez là je me vois j'aimerais bien
d'autre chose qu'une boîte et le cul
d'un chat ne me dites pas qu'on évoquait
non pas après avoir accompli tant
d'objectifs non mais un chat ne peut pas
être bloquée c'est la science qui
l'approuvent et voilà je sais si tu
pourrais nous remonter le moral
ouvrir un petit salon t si vous êtes à
l'aise pas du tout mais bon vivre quand
même tea party simulateur 2014 radical
changement d'ambiance au foot et
d'aborder la saison avec un chat il a
pas préparé du petit est ok c'est parti
et click to start mail ou gmail mais
qu'est-ce que ça va changer c'est le
sexe du nounours comme un enfant bômale
long et de mal finalement
ok il est bien fait sans déconner au
mois d'août et où on s'appelle
éventuellement tu préfères que ça paie
j'ai choisi un homme alors pourquoi j'ai
du vernis aux tirs toi jeune drâa ça
marche
voilà tu es à la renverse nos rencontres
au cégep eto'o aura plus aucun seysses
après il sera bannie des nounours à tout
jamais tu as de l'ombre tu les en fait
peter pan [ __ ] a lâché un scénariste
pour le prochain transformers je vous
promets mais du coup on va voir ce que
ça change si on prenait faux mails basse
et le bras c'est exactement le même bras
et la même main il a juste retiré les
poils du bras quoi le scandale on appris
du thé ouais on sait pas trop comment
bonsoir je suis professeur xavier mais
version papier en fait contre le papier
c'est un peu moins stylet mais bon j'ai
notamment gagné de nombreux concours
d'avions en papier puisque je les ai
volé de manière illimitée up
déjà on va verser l'eau dans le truc ça
va ça aurait pu être pire ça se remplit
ça se remplit monga à temps mais c'est
carrément pas du thé qui tombe c'est des
billes ne va pas faire une partie de
billes me boire du thé on va dire que
c'est bon ça dégage
si je comprends bien ce truc vient de me
traiter de novices ou encore bad ou que
sais tu pas content tu fais ton tu es tu
te calmes tu t'en vas d'ici viens viens
avec moi
tel avait prévu le coup et celui de la
clue sur les fesses il est colère la
table vient beauty n'ai pas peur de moi
top cet âge l'arraché
au nord c'est la tuer une salle parce
qu'on avait plus le bras avec des poils
voilà le break des poils nous encourage
à faire sauter ça c'est la bourgeoisie
ou sous peu aux petites heures tu t'en
vas d'ici j'ai dit attendre mais ces
dames quoi mais je me fais victimiser
par une serviette à temps aux tiens moi
je te grattes honteux parquet qu'est ce
que tu vas faire mon gars je sais ce que
tu vas faire tu vas commencer par lui
cacher les yeux parce qu'il m'énerve il
juge la cuillère ou le met dans la tasse
on leur pose délicatement c'est encore
pire mais on la ramasse du sol n'y a pas
de preuve oui un poisson l'ammoniac
healthcare poissions fait ici que fais
tu là et tu es un espion du gouvernement
juste là ouais ouais ouais à temps mais
ça fait peur sans déconner j'ai plus eu
peur en voyant sa conjointe aux classes
qu'est ce qui vient de se passer qu'il a
fait tout ça pourquoi ce poisson ont
fait 22 m moi tout ce qui m'attire dans
ce jeu c'est les poissons les beaux
poissons comme ça le petit doigt il fait
vraiment la noblesse comme je suis une
jante personnes pensent qu'on est dessus
je suis pas sûr après puisqu'on voit
rien mais à mon avis on est dessus
attendait mais là ça se passe super bien
en dehors du fait qu'il ya un gros à
mater là bas mais ça ivoirien lorsqu'il
est un jeu c'est qu'on est vraiment un
bras qui vont le regarder il n'y a pas
de cornier mauvais d'un bout à l'autre
de la map sans aucun problème
et ensuite il nous faut une part de
gâteau alors ça je vous avoue que j'ai
absolument aucune idée de comment on va
faire une part du gâteau je suppose il
faut prendre ce couteau déjà bien placé
sous le bientôt de sorte à ce qu'on
galère je te servir de celui là ça sent
le tube est trop loin donc t'as pas trop
le choix
quoi mais j'ai coupé devant le gâteau et
ça me fait grand noir mais c'est
scandaleux
mais il y avait un complot entre le
gâteau le messali tous quoi ce qui
explique pourquoi l'agent poisson était
la droite sur le bord gouvernement dans
l'histoire complot et terrorisme
ah ouais bah vous allez parce que c'est
vous à voir ce que ben bravo la bindra
sur ta tête tu vois plus rien et pendant
tu vois plus rien je te cram la tête
biatch aux plats bon bain de thé oberoi
arditi voilà agent zéro zéro fiche mais
tu vas dans le néant mon gars cette
agression scandaleuse
ensuite trois mètres de ce complot font
déjà rage et toi jeune couteau qui vient
avec moi
falcone cut up brisé le coeur je
complétais trois faux pas ce serait
moins douloureux oui notre revanche et
l'allégeance et déjà poser des mots sur
père courait sur tea party simulator
j'espère que ça vous a plu
et si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
alléguer votre maison ou appartement à
votre chat il en fera très bon usage
il peut être à tous voilà tout
simplement on se retrouve très vite dans
une nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
tu as tout le monde
pis c'est mieux
[Musique]
oh